but these things for both males and
females he sees what he said is worse
than taking the hijab off if he meant
what he said yeah and he believes in
what he said yeah it has way worse
ramifications okay good
all right now
[Music]
Oh
by any so high level feed the power
[Music]
assalamualaikum Idaho today better care
to brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you got to do well in sha Allah
before I start when appraisal also kind
of what Allah the most merciful the most
trust or praises glory and gratitude
belong to him we are in New York City
Times Square is right behind behind that
hamdulillah we've been here Mohammed II
job had a debate we're gonna put a link
inshaallah to that he had a debate
against a very big stomach oh he's been
attacking the religion mocking the
religion and hamdulillah he absolutely
got intellectually destroyed anyway so
you can watch that video we highly
recommend you to watch the video in sha
allah but let's come to the straight
point to our topic today inshallah so
basically as you know about before we
came to new york i did a video about our
sister Dina and i which i haven't
watched so much yeah you haven't watch
yeah but it was good handle on just a my
point across you know and exceptionally
just read about the hijab you know why
women wear the hijab and i just brought
the sister Dina's issue into is what I'm
just given be able to see into her and
obviously into the sisters by watching
as well so now this is a new video that
came out you know a podcast between her
and her husband yeah I was hearing a
yeah I was doing awesome yes I was
revising it for my in the Bible cuz I
wanted here we see like why you know you
know why she chose to go down there
because she's outside in the day you
know it gives us an understanding of the
psychology of our sisters why they take
their land obviously as Salam this is
what we do we try to help our youth in
all the things shall I make practicing
the religion easier for them for them to
love Islamic sir so that's why I keep an
eye on these kinds of things
I don't watch every single video over
this but it caught my attention I
justjust to be clear like I mean with
this whole thing my position on the
matter is that what I heard from the
podcast is that my sister Dina hi name
is yeah yeah she made a paper pin the
clear that she doesn't believe that
she's representing like Islam or
anything like that in what she do it
yeah I think she's just requires our
support like she needs her support and
assistance and you know you can talk
about of I have a voice to be honest
with me this seems like she's going
through some kind of yeah possibly I'm
not I'm not trying to read into this but
it could be actually
and psychological issues as well it can
be though she seems a little bit like
she'd go through things in life Lois you
can't even see that in the podcast that
came back you know that she's upset and
I just wanna make it before I'm gonna go
check the reaction but before we do I
just want to say to the people who are
calling her you're a disgrace or this
please fix up don't be stupid and silly
your own wife your sister can go through
this yeah we have to support yes we've
made it clear what's been done is it's
in she acknowledges it you know I think
if that doesn't need to be made clear in
a smile written below well I heard from
what she said is that she didn't even
know she didn't consider herself a job
before three years yeah
so yes range which is the podcast we've
got certain bits that we're going to
react and show me about because people
obviously like I see what's going on
because I'm at astatine is hip
probably not hips it has something else
if you okay so just to give you know
briefly because we didn't we we were
talking about we don't want to go
through the whole thing with you guys
here it's just she talked cities talking
to Dina for the whole issue etc etc the
reason why we this video is called
reacting to sins and not Dina here's the
reason why you can understand because
obviously she's talking excetera about
why she chose that decision blah blah we
are more concentrated on what's about to
happen now this is what we are really
concentrated about there's a buildup as
it kind of gets worse with our brother
sit and we fought it it isn't a becoming
an alarm level where we had to say
something about to so this is one of the
things solved he's seen I just repeat
again yeah we'll just go back again yet
you were talking about because people
obviously like I see what's going on
because I'm at astatine his hip probably
not hips it has something else but if
you're gonna do start doing these things
well I didn't do that's not about what's
not allowed make a few come on mister
cards podcast mister cause jokes
listen to me thanks okay listen thanks
babe okay so no this is one of the first
vulgar comments yeah and I'm something
to use word like air or which which I've
seen on a few other videos which we've
assumed the best in said okay well you
go respect and do you know there she's
she's standing her ground and trying to
striving sensitize
this is what I was kind of like a bit
surprised about here because a lot of
people in the comment section
I'm having a go at ordinary took a hijab
of eccentric cetera what if it may be
okay she's acknowledged okay but what
surprises me and shocks me and this is a
big phenomenon within the Muslim
community is that for some reason they
think the hijab be the head covering a
modesty is something holistic it come to
the whole it's not a segment of listen
that not a single person in the comment
section came and said sit
why are you talking in anymore destroy
buffer okay I went through I was just
going to just to see what people's
perspectives I didn't come across the
computer on I didn't come across a
single common that's it
sit why use your vocal language you know
where's your modesty muscle that's the
interesting point do you know what is
very strict I had these on these kind of
things where yes you start making like
sexual innuendos but you're making
sexual references yeah and there's a
hadith of the Prophet Muhammad SAW
Isilon when he told us that the worst of
creatures are those individuals who
expose their sexual what they're doing
my private
publicly and stuff but to be completely
honest with you you didn't go there he
didn't know he's doing there with that
sounds a very I don't to be more
explicit what is he actually making
reference to but I think a lot of people
would know exactly what rhyming
reference to me it's a sexual act of
some sorts so frankly like I'm happier
at dinner kind of stood our ground at
that I do respect that yeah and that's
what I do that's what we need to do like
when they find their husband you know
going to go in away from the Sharia um
and doing things are not know even just
against Islam right this is kind of
inappropriate kind of stuff it's good I
she took a stand I believe yeah
I just wanna make if you're watching
this but like we don't have nothing
personal against you I'm making it very
clear what I'm doing is it's just we're
gonna come to why we did this video
we're gonna find out but let's just
watch I just know for me I personally
would have been upset but like this is
not the main thing if you're gonna give
advice there's a way you're doing it
it's not it's not a thing of if you're
gonna give advice not advice there's a
way don't give your advice this
principle is wrong but for their part is
wrong like Maceo the core sort of seldom
said that the beam is Nasir you have to
give advice yet and the law says in the
Quran that let there arise amongst you a
group of people who'll enjoin good and
forbid evil and we even have a different
processor who said if you do not enjoin
good and forbid evil Allah will send
down a calamity but even if you push
straightly reject it for me thank you
for that but I want to just I don't know
I don't know what the context is exactly
I said before well I would just say at
the end Edina says don't don't give
advice she said advising Lee you did
give Nasir to sit when he made up
inappropriate things I don't know if you
say a few advisory we don't you advise
it's a contradiction because you've
given them that oh okay I see what you
mean yeah but maybe she's just come in
at that angle but unless I've missed
something I miss something K but much
maybe she's making thinking to those who
are criticized and maybe we'll assume
the best maybe she's saying to those who
are really harsh like but I would I
don't want that kind of owe me maybe
yeah I think I know the context unless
assume the best advice is the wrong word
maybe just just some words because I've
seen I've seen I've seen people to have
something to say they say it in a way
they disagree with you they say well
what's not funny about that I don't
understand III have a responsibility I
affect you if you do every single public
figure has that responsibility on their
shoulders it is I possibly there's
nothing funny about it
it's
yeah okay she gave another you give
another nice your sister you actually
gave another advice that you acknowledge
that you are and I put her for that I
applauded that she understand that she's
a public figure that's I applaud them
when I approve that okay let's lose all
my following no face like I appreciate
the following I appreciate you guys I do
and you guys have stuck around but you
actually can't be disappointed that
you're not my everything wow that's deep
you know that's deep that every single
one of us are gonna honor their
judgement yeah always ensure were
amongst the righteous ones but we're
gonna ask them be that look I'm free
from you I don't know none of you all
know anyone that's coming to take a
picture with me brother we don't do
respect unless one of the righteous
people other than that I'm gonna say
look I don't know you and she said it
very she said look you're not my
everything I actually learned from that
cause I think that we can all get into
this me you everything she's a she's a
social media person she's got a big full
of the business she actually much bigger
than both of us put together yeah right
and I learned from that that she's come
she's gone for a journey where she's
realized that's how la Fame doesn't
equate happiness yeah and a lot of
people go through that journey and I
think she's kind of come to that
realization so it's a good lesson for
all of us and I think we could learn
from someone like Dean of an inspector
because she's gone to see she's see much
more than we had in terms of Fame and
publish in these things and she's come
to certain conclusions nothing that's
just you know you're not my everything
my life is separate from social media
and these videos social media doesn't
equip my happiness so it is a profound I
would say it's like a logical kind of
realization to really train this region
I'd be happy to lose you guys and go and
have to work in a regular nine-to-five
so the Chinese are quite strong I should
do really call you [ __ ] okay so here
right here he's talking about those
people in the Twitter who are involved
in MMA or something like that that are
that's calling her a disgrace you so
he's having a go at them and seen you
are this
so did you see what he just said that
yeah so he's using the word he's using
it's bigger the see but he's use the
word penis yeah so he's saying you've
only seen one he's talking to his wife
and this video has gone viral and you
say no yeah but you've only seen one
yeah what my brother said well like what
I'm just as well just hard to hire you
why did you find the need to say that
what's the need of using foul language
is that what benefit does it bring to
you and you know what might what I said
about she seems to have I dunno I to be
honest with you just as someone who's
kind of seen this for the first time in
and heard them properly like for a long
period of time I've come across their
videos before but not and this long kind
of conversational style Dena comes
across as much more serious and to be
honest with you I feel like Dena has a
lot more to offer just as a as a person
and I feel like Sid in order to
overcompensate for this he might be
trying to be a bit more ridiculous
people more frivolous capricious because
he I think he realizes that the audience
is more concerned about his wife has to
say and if that's the case I would say
that look you don't need to do this in
order to be recognized frankly I mean
you don't need to go down this route of
vulgarity and over capriciousness just
just have some self decorum follow your
wife's advice your wife is right you
should just have a self but she said
have a filter you know there's certain
things you say sentence you don't have
was very important because to me it's
not it was constraint okay Dena's took
over her job of once again she's
acknowledged and we've said that it's a
sinner advice everybody just general but
over here it seems to me more that we
are more concentrated on the outer
common than the inner one like the inner
modesty because over here I'm sorry
buddy jobs I'm sorry
SIDS career Rose sits modesty I'm sorry
it's it's it's not nice to present is
awesome
dignified this is nice it's not I feel
like yeah from just for the first time
yeah that dealer seems a little bit more
self control yeah you know but city's
not it's really not now I'm just into
you as a bottle of lights nice okay so
this is I'm sorry I apologize
I think that it's very imperative that a
woman's right in Islam yeah she got
first of all be treated of kindness yeah
but also she has a right to a man that
really has a lot of stuff did knee you
know and if a man consistently in a
husband-wife relationship kind of
disrespects himself if you like care and
in the public saying they know that a
wife she's been in in a sense
she's been deprived of her rights
because you are representative of your
wife you offer each other and if you're
looking like that your wife is not very
comfortable with it my advice to you
brother is that you know you take a
wife's advice seriously she seems to be
you know controlling discussion there
but more has a little bit more once
again self control have a filter my life
this conversation is okay so this is the
part we had yeah this is know why cuz
it's dumb for me it's really dumb for me
because before I met Dina before Dina
before I met Dana is this a thing is
this a thing women I know because I'm
you know just know I want to say
religious but I used to be like I'm a
little bit I think you'll quick I I
think about it I think I'm a better
person for sure I'm a better person now
than I was before when I was on the deep
alright so this seems to be the biggest
most egregious problem or this comment
he is saying if I've understood it
correctly because it's completely
apparent from what he's saying this is
what he's using a comparative English
language
what better to signify that his life or
his morality had improved as a result of
distancing himself away from the Deen
religion and the specific example Islam
my first question to will be from where
do you get your moral Anchorage how do
you derive morality where do you choose
how do you know what is right and wrong
from where do you get what is right and
wrong
you know from an objective level so here
because the fingers we as Muslims we
believe as you know that Allah who is
the creator of the heavens and the earth
he sent prophets and these prophets are
sinless prophets who guide people to the
straight path the Quran says in kuntum
to her boon Allah fat tubby ani you will
become Allah if you love Allah then
follow me I eat the Prophet Muhammad and
Allah will love you back so the
maximally perfect model the ausrotten
hassan and from an Islamic perspective
is of Muhammad and all the other
prophets that came it's like a perfect
example yeah
so if you're saying that by getting
closer to this model
you're becoming a worse person then this
would contradict the premise of Islam on
a fundamental level so you need to
reassess my advice to you Baba would be
for you to reassess where do you
actually get your morality from what do
you consider a good thing what did you
consider a bad thing
what do you consider what makes you good
what makes you bad in these things as
Muslims we say that which is closer to
the Sunnah of the Prophet Muhammad and
all the other prophets are good things
and those which are further away from it
are bad things and finally I want to say
one other thing which I feel a little
bit ironic innocence and this might
sound a little bit harsh and I apologize
if it does come across like that I'm not
trying to be that yeah but it seems like
your wife obviously she was I had a job
Rizzuto eNOS or something like that yeah
so clearly she relied on a Muslim
community in order to propel herself to
this position that she's in to make a
living you were assisted by her on going
to social
Media and it seems like now this is the
feeling at your biting the hand that fed
you because the Muslim community who are
being referenced implicitly throughout
this whole podcast double jab the
community stringent did the Muslim
community who brought you up now you're
trying to distance yourself away from
them and you're kind of almost kind of
placing blame on them but this part here
is even more egregious in now because
you're saying that the Deen itself the
religion itself being further away from
it has improved you so you're gonna have
to retract that same in my opinion and
you're gonna have to reconsider where
you get your morality from otherwise
it's just gonna be a case of some some
Muslims it's just gonna be a case it's
just gonna be a case off for me like
someone who has has internally he's been
telling lies like a colonial criticism
of Islam yeah oriental criticism of
Islam this is that's what you come
across as tubulin sometimes said you
come across as someone who's trying to
trying to over prove his liberalism are
I'm moderate and liberal on these things
this is just thinking yourself away from
Islam in front of podcast when your wife
tried to have a few meaningful
conversations about religion you seem to
want to move away from there so I would
say look manda reassess the purpose of
life to be honest because you know
around the people at the book will never
be happy with you until you leave your
religion simple as that before you know
and it's very important for all of us is
a reminder to meet this man follow there
there were yeah we need to educate our
self on Islam because if you truly I'm
sure you do understand if you went a bit
in detail and studied your religion you
would understand the beauty of you not
say oh in mating I'm a better person
than I was before but let's see what
Dina says about this but you're
practicing you see that the fact that
sister Dina had to come in there and
interject and say that you are
practicing because it seemed like like
sitio coming across values not
practicing with that statement cause
Dina felt like you know you're saying it
made you a better person
like okay you're not letting me finish
my point Mike so I've got three sisters
two older one younger they never wore a
scarf 24/7 they just sometimes block it
on the head when people is like reciting
Quran or something to go into the mosque
just plunk your head Quicktime
no pins none of that pocket on your head
a little bit sometimes so when I met
Dean and I was like well you will wear
that 24/7 just just just sorry it's come
about this yeah I don't actually believe
I don't actually believe I'm sorry to
say I don't actually believe that your
level of ignorance has reached a level
where you don't actually think that
women put the headscarf every time
because it says it's a visible reality
like you all you have to do is walk in
the streets of London and you know that
women don't put their head down and
they're not sure what we're saying is we
just one shine highlight here is that
I'm sorry you can't have a you can't
just concentrate on sister Deena Wow
brother city same thing this is I'm
sorry I find it pathetic and especially
sisters I was expecting the sisters have
come out with at least a you know what
hold on it's just really important way
shows where we're at modesty is for both
males and females
this is not a the issue has been for me
the central issue yeah what he said is
worse than you know taking a job off if
you meant what he said yeah and he
believes in what he said yeah it has way
worse ramifications okay good all right
now I consider him yeah I consider him a
little bit unaware yeah I'm all these
Irwin teaming up I think he's a bit
unaware of the implications of what he's
saying yeah and I really I do genuinely
feel I hope hope really yeah that he
reconsiders number one what he's
actually saying number two where his
source of moral Anchorage comes from and
number three his purpose of life
generally and what is that ask yourself
question what is your purpose of life
yeah seriously and you just go back to
basics and then Charlotte things will
fall into place exactly so the fact that
bombs are just a wrap on just the fact
that we are concentrate more on sister
Dena's hijab which once again with
acknowledge and not what
said if we mention like that shows our
understanding of the religion we do not
understand it and we need to go down I
agree with the poor you're right it's
because it's embarrassing
we are more concentrated than that which
is its sinister of course it's wrong
this is going to suffer may Allah make
you suffer but sit seen that I'm not a
single comment not a single video on
this topic shows our priorities oh yeah
yeah I think you're absolutely right
yeah because she even said that
surviving consumer so behind Evan for
three years it's not hard to say that in
the podcast let's finish this man so
yeah just to finish this off do
something Lauren once again forgive us
it look we're not we're just here as
your brother will give me any advice
don't take this money from work we were
like we'll talk we'll eat one day if you
wanna come down yeah but nothing
personal Jewish corner whatever will
come out will you live near moose Arctic
yes I mean about flight to catch with
your mother catch we need to leave